We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hello, we are anonymous. Over the years, we have been watching you. First off, we should describe what anonymous is. It's not an organization. It is a non-organization. A sort of ever-changing band of individuals.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。了解更多信息请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。大家好，我们是匿名者。多年来，一直在默默注视着你们。首先，我们应该说明什么是匿名者。它不是一个组织。它是一个非组织。一种不断变化的人群。
Sometimes describe as hackers or activists or free expression zealots or just internet troublemakers. You can't even call them a group. I tend to call them a phenomenon. We are anonymous. And for someone who writes extensively about brands and brand identity, Rob Walker became intrigued. My name is Rob Walker.
有时被称为黑客、激进分子、言论自由狂热者，或者只是互联网上的麻烦制造者。你甚至不能称他们为一个群体。我倾向于称他们为一个现象。我们是匿名者。对于一个深入研究品牌和品牌认同的人来说，罗布·沃克对此产生了浓厚的兴趣。我叫罗布·沃克。
I'm a contributing writer for the New York Times magazine and for design observer. Because this non-group called anonymous, somehow created its own visual identity. It was so compelling and immediately recognizable, which is a task that corporations are political campaigns. It's been millions and millions of dollars to achieve, and these people seem to have done
我是《纽约时报杂志》和设计观察者的特约撰稿人。因为这个被称为匿名者的非群体，不知何故创造了自己的视觉形象。它是如此引人注目且极具辨识度，而这正是企业和政治竞选花费数百万美元才能达到的目标，而这些人似乎做到了这一点。
something very effective without any organization or any budget or even any coherent plan. There are two basic images used for anonymous. One is a logo. A headless figure in a suit juxtaposed against a kind of world map that's very blatantly derived from the United Nations Globe logo with a question mark where his head should be. The other major visual image is a mask. That is a sort of stylized visage based on Guy Fox although no one really recognizes Guy Fox. It's the mask wornwarmed by the protagonist
无需任何组织、预算甚至连贯的计划，就取得了非常显著的效果。关于匿名者有两个基本的视觉形象。一个是标志。一个身穿西装的无头人形，与一个显然改编自联合国地球标志的世界地图并置在一起，在他本该是头部的地方是一个问号。另一个主要的视觉形象是一个面具。那是一种基于盖伊·福克斯的风格化面孔，尽管并没有多少人真正了解盖伊·福克斯。那是主角戴的面具
and the graphic novel in that movie, V for Vendetta. The original mass design was by the artist David Lloyd. And it comes in handy when you're trying to stay anonymous in the real world. And it is sort of leeched over into just street protests in general. Street protests like the non-affiliated Occupy Wall Street movement.
出自小说和电影《V字仇杀队》。最初的面具设计者是艺术家大卫·劳埃德。当你试图在现实世界中保持匿名时，它非常派上用场。而且它也蔓延到了普通的街头抗议活动中。诸如无党派的“占领华尔街”运动等街头抗议。
Anonymous has its roots in the anonymous postings on the Slash B-Sash message board on ForChand.org. I would openly discourage your listeners from visiting the Slash B-Sash message board. Yeah, some things you just can't unsee. It's really pretty harsh. But an anonymous came together as a kind of movement when they decided to take on the church of Scientology. There was an embarrassing video of Tom Cruise that people were posting and people representing the church of Scientology were taking it down. We are the authorities on getting people of drugs. We are the authorities on the mind. And people associated with an anonymous had a problem with that because of their kind of general
匿名者的根源在于 4chan.org 网站的 /b/ 版块上的匿名发帖。我公开劝阻听众不要去访问 /b/ 版块。是的，有些东西一旦看到就无法抹去。它确实相当残酷。但是，当匿名者决定向科学教派宣战时，他们作为一个运动凝聚在了一起。当时有一段汤姆·克鲁斯的尴尬视频被人们发布出来，而代表科学教派的人却在将其删除。我们是帮人戒毒的权威。我们是心灵的权威。而与匿名者相关的人对此有异议，因为他们那种普遍的
free expression point of view and decided that they would band together and keep reposting that video and then that sort of escalated into what else can we do to basically cause problems for the Church of Scientology. It was an ominous YouTube video produced by a small subset of anonymous where a more unified voice began to form. I was absolutely blown away by this video. It's directed to the Church of Scientology.
言论自由的观点，并决定联合起来继续重新发布这段视频，随后这演变成“我们还能做些什么来给科学教派制造麻烦”。这是一个由匿名者的一个小分支制作的充满威胁意味的 YouTube 视频，在那里开始形成了一种更统一的声音。这段视频让我绝对惊艳。它是针对科学教派的。
It's not directed to the world at large. It just sort of says, you know, attention, Church of Scientology, we are anonymous. And here's what we have to say. And we're coming after you. And we recognize you as a formidable opponent, but we're going to take you down. And the visuals, it's just sort of rolling clouds over buildings.
它不是针对整个世界的。它只是说，你知道，注意了，科学教派，我们是匿名者。这就是我们要说的话。我们要来找你们了。我们承认你们是一个强大的对手，但我们要击垮你们。至于视觉效果，它只是建筑物上空翻滚的云彩。
And there's this kind of ominous music playing in the background. And the voiceover is this robot voice. Which turned out to be an online AT&D text to speech translator. But it sounds really creepy. There are a few notable moments and turns of phrase in the video, but the first one to grab Rob's attention said, We are anonymous and we're going to do this for the good of your own followers, for the good of mankind, and for our own amusement, kind, and
背景音乐带有一种不祥的意味。而画外音是机器人声音。这后来被证明是一个在线 AT&T 文本转语音翻译器。但听起来真的很毛骨悚然。视频中有几个值得注意的时刻和措辞，但首先抓住罗布注意力的一句是：我们是匿名者，为了你们追随者的利益，为了人类的利益，也为了我们自己的娱乐，为了
for our own enjoyment. Which just sort of like really encapsulates this like we're righteous and we just sort of feel like doing this right now because we find it fun. Which is really kind of a scary combination of ideas. The video ends with what has become the anonymous tagline. And parts of this tagline I learned had been kind of floating around on 4chan that slash be slashboard. We are anonymous.
我们自己的乐趣，我们要这么做。这恰好概括了这种“我们代表正义，我们现在觉得好玩所以就像这么做”的心态。这确实是一种相当吓人的理念组合。视频的最后是后来成为匿名者标语的一句话。我了解到，这句标语的一部分一直在 4chan 的 /b/ 版块上流传。我们是匿名者。
We are Legion. We do not forgive. We do not forget. Expect us. Expect us is so like, you know, you just almost immediately want to sort of freeze up at your keyboard and look over your shoulder to see if they're there. Around the same time as this video, the aforementioned headless suitman in front of the UN flag logo was created. Again, using elements that have been floating around the slash B-slash board for quite some time, they also created a website, and all this because a media savvy member of anonymous
我们是军团。我们不饶恕。我们不忘记。等着瞧吧。“等着瞧吧”这种话，你知道的，几乎会让你立刻想在键盘前僵住，然后回头看看他们是不是就在你身后。大约在这段视频发布的同时，前面提到的、位于联合国旗标标志前的无头西装人被创造出来了。同样，利用在 /b/ 版块上流传了一段时间的元素，他们还建立了一个网站，这一切都因为一个精通媒体的匿名者成员
warned the others that if they didn't brand themselves, someone else would do it for them. You need some kind of a solid identity to present to the press because they're going to come up with their own if you don't and you want to control that message. Rob Walker got the inside story of the early days of anonymous from Greg Housh, who was part of the early planners of various anonymous actions. You could say directing the action, but you know, with anonymous everyone knows that you can only make suggestions that if they're good enough and people like them, they'll do it.
警告其他人，如果他们不为自己塑造品牌，别人就会代劳。你需要向媒体展示某种坚定的身份认同，因为如果你不这样做，他们就会自己捏造一个，而你想掌控这个信息。罗布·沃克从格雷格·豪什那里独家了解了匿名者早期的故事，格雷格是各种匿名者行动早期策划者之一。你可以说是在指导行动，但你知道，对于匿名者，每个人都知道你只能提出建议，如果这些建议足够好并且人们喜欢，他们就会去做。
But they could have easily been ignored. In the process of being as bombastic as they could towards Scientology, they sort of accidentally created this ominous self-image that is simultaneously scary but also very attractive, I think. So this video that they did took off, currently it has over 4.5 million views, and they decided the next logical step was street protest. We decided right then and there, that's what we're gonna ask everyone to do. We're gonna send the internet outside. People are leaving their mother's basement. But by this point there
但它们也很容易被忽视。在他们对科学教派表现得极其夸张的过程中，他们有点无意中创造了一种不祥的自我形象，既可怕又非常吸引人，我认为。所以他们制作的这段视频火了，目前它的观看次数已超过 450 万，他们决定下一步合乎逻辑的举动是进行街头抗议。我们当机立断决定，这就是我们要号召大家去做的。我们要把互联网带到户外。人们正在离开他们母亲的地下室。但到了这个时候
was sort of legal stuff in motion with church Scientology was really going after them. The first thing that came to my mind was okay we're gonna need to cover our bases. So we need a mask, what mask do we use? We build a short list of you know-Mask. He means the V for a Vendetta mask. That's kind of symbolic, a Batman mask. The actual one that came in kind of second in our voting that night was Old School Masquerade masks, where you would actually hold the little thick and hold it up.
科学教派已经有一些法律动作在进行了，他们真的在追捕他们。我脑海中浮现的第一件事是，好吧，我们需要做好万全准备。所以我们需要一个面具，用哪个面具呢？我们建立了一个候选名单，你知道的——面具。他指的是《V字仇杀队》的面具。那具有某种象征意义，还有蝙蝠侠的面具。那天晚上在我们的投票中实际位居第二的是老式化妆舞会面具，那种需要你拿着一根小柄举在脸前的面具。
And we came up with like five or six masks. And then they got really pragmatic about their choice. We called around to comic book shops and costume shops in most of the major cities in the world from Paris to London to New York to LA, I mean, everywhere. And we asked, you know, do you have any of these and you know, what do they cost? And the most thing we found was nearly every costume
我们想出了五六个面具。然后他们对选择变得非常务实。我们给世界上大多数主要城市的漫画店和服装店打了电话，从巴黎到伦敦、纽约到洛杉矶，我是说，到处都打遍了。我们问，你知道，你们有这些吗，多少钱？我们发现最多的是，地球上几乎每家服装
and comic book shop on this planet had that beef of a net a version of the Guy Fox mask for six to $10, depending on your local currency. And it was just, it was okay, there we go. It's available, it is cheap, and it's in every city in the world. Not only do we like it, but it's the right choice. And basically the upshot is enough people went along with that, that the day after these Scientology protests
店和漫画店都有那种《V字仇杀队》版本的盖伊·福克斯面具，售价在 6 到 10 美元之间，取决于当地货币。当时的想法就是，好吧，就它了。它随处可买，便宜，而且世界上的每个城市都有。不仅我们喜欢它，而且这是正确的选择。基本上结果就是，足够多的人接受了这一点，以至于在这些科学教派抗议活动发生的第二天
happened, there were photos and videos of people wearing this mask all over the place and it just caught fire. It was a powerful thing that people sort of saw it and said that's anonymous. Another quality of the V for Vendetta mask is that it has its own twisted version of a Mona Lisa smile that you can't quite figure out if he's laughing or mean or laughing at you in a mean way. And I think having fun and menace, you know, it's not really that surprising that those two ideas would be linked. It is a statement of anonymity, of personal privacy, but it's also a statement of wild freedom of expression and absolutely through a combination of birth and menace.
到处都是戴着这个面具的人的照片和视频，它一下子就火了。这是一件很有力量的事情，人们看到它就会说，那是匿名者。《V字仇杀队》面具的另一个特质是，它带着一种扭曲的蒙娜丽莎式的微笑，你很难分清他是在笑，还是表情恶劣，或者是带着恶意的笑在嘲笑你。我认为将娱乐和威胁结合起来，你知道，将这两个概念联系在一起其实并不令人意外。这是一种关于匿名性、个人隐私的宣言，但它也是一种对狂野言论自由的宣言，绝对是通过恶作剧和威胁的结合来实现的。
So when I ask Rob Walker why he thinks these two images, the headless suitman and the v for vendetta mask work, he gives two basic reasons. One is that they're just graphically pleasing. Sometimes what hangs people up is like, what is your empirical proof that this is good? And it's like, well, I don't really have any empirical proof. What I have is, I look at it and I say, that's awesome. And the second reason is that the two symbols are easy to manipulate. With a very simple graphics program, you can put the GuyFox mask thing over the headless suit guy. You can manipulate these things in any number of ways, which is a strategy that a traditional, say, corporate brand or political campaign wouldn't maybe not be so into.
所以当我问罗布·沃克为什么他认为这两个形象——无头西装人和《V字仇杀队》面具能够奏效时，他给出了两个基本原因。一是它们在视觉上很讨喜。有时人们纠结的是，你有什么实证证明这是好的？而答案是，嗯，我真的没有任何实证。我有的只是，我看着它，然后说，这太棒了。第二个原因是这两个符号很容易操纵。通过一个非常简单的图形程序，你可以把盖伊·福克斯面具戴在无头西装人身上。你可以用各种各样的方式操纵这些东西，这是一种传统的、比如说企业品牌或政治竞选可能不会那么感兴趣的策略。
But in this case, there was no creative brief, there was no set of brand standards. People just seem to intuitively know that you can play around with these things and draw on the power of them, but make them your own, and in the making them your own, you're doing it in a way that rebounds back to the original images and makes them even stronger. And that's just like the message board meme culture that spawned anonymous to begin with. You can make the images your own and be one of them. Or use it for your own purposes and have nothing to do with anonymous at all. No one will know the difference.
但在这种情况下，没有创意简报，没有一套品牌标准。人们似乎只是凭直觉知道你可以摆弄这些东西并借用它们的力量，但要打造出你自己的风格，而在打造你自己的风格的过程中，你的做法会反作用于最初的形象，使其更加强大。这就像是孕育了匿名者的迷因（meme）文化。你可以将这些形象据为己有，成为他们的一员。或者将其用于你自己的目的，与匿名者毫无关系。没有人会察觉到区别。
And these icons and anonymous will live on. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Rob Walker and me Roman Mars. It's based off an article that Rob wrote for Slate. I'll have a link on the website. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute
这些标志和匿名者将长存。本周的《99% Invisible》由罗布·沃克和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。它改编自罗布为《Slate》杂志撰写的一篇文章。我会在网站上发布链接。本程序由 Lunar 提供支持，用创意创造不同。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 的一个项目，旧金山美国建筑师学会
of Architects in San Francisco, in the Center for Architecture and Design. 99% invisible is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public, find out more at PRX.org. The program intern is named Sam Greenspan. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, you can follow me on Twitter at Roman Morris or you can just join us at the website at 99%Invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和建筑与设计中心也有参与。99% Invisible 由 PRX（公共广播交流中心）发行，致力于让公共广播更加普及，了解更多信息请访问 PRX.org。本节目的实习生是萨姆·格林斯潘。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并给本节目点赞，你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMorris，或者直接访问我们的网站 99%Invisible.org。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。